Before I get started I want you to smile. Are you smiling? Okay, keep smiling.
Many researchers have found the benefits of the facial feedback effect. For
example, one group of researchers that did an experiment similar to the one we
just did with the pen in making people smile, found that participants who had
the pen in their teeth forcing them to smile. Found a cartoon to be more
amusing, than participants who are frowning. I find this research to truly be
amazing, and can actually benefit you in your everyday life. Because our face
is so much more than just a tool to express emotion. It can actually encourage
and promote feelings. For example, one group of researchers found that patients
reported feeling better after receiving Botox injections in their eyebrow to
paralyze the frowning muscles. After only two months, nine out of ten patients
said that they were no longer depressed and felt better. This stuff is truly
amazing.